it's gotta try and find to you on
youtubes okay yeah well but you can't
you can't cheat though no I'll pause you
like I did the other one okay yeah yeah
I can't I can't see you just yet
yeah there's probably like okay cool
so anyway hi guys for when you see this
I am yang man
your host and this is Amy hi now we have
literally just got this game we don't
really know how to play it so I'm very
sorry if this is annoying to watch but
yeah we've already both gonna be
extremely bad but we just went through
the tutorial I'm gonna play spike party
so and these were both playing it
together we're both gonna be pretty bad
so yeah we've just done this tutorial
and that was fine yeah it was fine but
now let's see how how bad we are
yeah not convinced that it's gonna be
okay scary bad it's okay we can play
this again at some point we'll get ya
we'll get below it's okay we is all
about hey actual Bono's hey young king
kid hey SEPA hadn't Zayn hey Maria Hayes
Joe San and young teen kid said hello
Amy oh hi
I still can't see you guys yeah I'm
trying to find where have you put this
have you put it on YouTube
yeah yeah it's on YouTube and twitch I
can't find you guys compliant young
blind oh well you know on YouTube you
should be on if you just refresh the
page it's
say that I'm live no I'm just checking
that I haven't stupidly made it like
private or something now it's public
yeah
what's if I go in your channel that's
how I usually find it
mm-hmm hey to taberna Maria's surname is
pizza
I don't think actually it what maybe is
that's a cool surname hmm oh there we
are okay I've got you yeah yeah
can you see young king cake oreo cheer
yes okay I'm gonna pause you
I don't secretly have the stream pulled
up a very poor sit cross my heart
I trust Sammy's a little trust Amy yeah
everyone Amy the voice Amy the Enigma
well I'm in some of your videos so yeah
that's true if you want to take you'll
find Amy finally I said joshan's name
completely wrong I'm sorry probably
butchered it again just then oh well how
did you say I don't know Joe shame shame
shame
hey s 6:9 Bissell Bissell Bissell how
you doing good thanks I had my three
months of you and work and I still have
a job
yay well done congratulation thanks
okay so let's play do you want to be a
spy first or a sniper first you want to
be a spy I feel like I'll be completely
obvious it's okay I feel like I'm gonna
totally [ __ ] fail this
either way so okay you can be a spy and
I'll be sleeping
hashtag trust Amy who should up be
decision have to wait for you now yeah I
know I'm taking okay guys you can help
me you can be my my like third fourth
fifth six how many of you there are eyes
that's cheating
well your team apparently so I can cheek
to you okay yeah yeah yeah okay okay
hey premier I'm gonna be you only get
one shot do know that unity comes within
a lifetime okay are we the same okay
it's it doing except I need you to
accept right I know you're the watcher
dude I see you wait okay so I don't pick
this oh I did pick this guy
what do you mean I'm the wheelchair dude
catch you off guard
but I thought I picked a different guy
so ok mr. loud I want to turn it down I
don't go with you find out please tell
me what are you setting escape settings
audio and then you can turn it down
there there we go
oh that's lots better okay okay um what
am i doing okay right okay so I can you
can't choose the waiter no huh you can't
choose like the waiter and stuff no this
tutorial okay cool so I'm starting to D
highlight them maybe that one banana
bread thing I don't know Tony done that
mate [ __ ]
that's the time okay I do need to like
up my game there
is it harsh yeah it's actually really
hard I have no [ __ ] clue well I don't
know there's one person I think you
might be and I guess I'll just wait and
shoot that person don't just shoot
random civilians Yasmin that's not okay
banana Brian how many times you have to
do that
I don't know wait my god guys who do you
think she is I look over I just see what
about him choice of game no tell me who
she is
oh god we've got a minute oh my god do
we yeah not reading a shot well we can
stop in a minute okay I really wanted to
be the queen but I knew you'd guess the
Queen yeah she's a queen yeah and the
young king kids right you can have fake
banana bread so you can say it like more
than once so mm-hmm
says I'm waiting for you so how do I get
out of this replay I guess escape oh
yeah
I didn't bother yes okay so if anyone
doesn't know if anyone hasn't seen this
game before basically either I am a spy
or a me as a spy and the other person is
a sniper and you have missions to do
such as saying banana bread to another
person or or putting a bug on another
person and you need to do that being
inconspicuous yeah and you can up the
time so there's a time limit and you can
up the time by checking your time by a
window and that will put the time up but
other people will do that like randomly
anyway like the NPC's kind of do that
anyway so you as the sniper needs to
realize who's checking their time and
when the time goes up and yeah I did it
and then you were like oh you should
look at your watch I was like I can't
believe I stood on the side it's like
you're the watcher I thought you were
like what I didn't realize I picked that
guy because it just shows her faces
obviously so I was just like oh I'm
gonna go with this guy and then I that's
why I sounded confused because I was the
guy that wheelchair didn't
fair enough fair enough I was convincing
because it was true for MINIX I don't
realize those that date oh I don't think
it takes wait am i this by now am I the
sniper again whoa oh I'm the spy okay I
don't actually know who I am because I
didn't take anyone
so we'll say it surprised me too okay
all right all right how do I do that
saying again so
oh so you don't like start off you you
can like control whenever you want to
that's interesting yeah you just oh gosh
this is hard
yeah right mm-hmm
oh that's ambassador
wait this two of the same person I think
that was this person yeah I definitely
think it was that person were you happy
with who you picked I don't I don't care
I don't get this person in the end of
bread yeah being sneaky
okay I don't think it's that person
anymore this is really difficult okay I
think it's this person i'ma shoot cuz
there was two of you and I thought you
were the other guy that looked exactly
like you that's not that and then I
swapped and I thought you were like
evilly laughing so you must be doing
something Nikki Nikki don't you bloody
dare give a me tips Nikki I didn't see
that haha you are my side what is this
Nikki knows what's up
[Music]
what no I only got it cuz you didn't
evil laugh and I know what you like that
means you're up to something
[Laughter]
unlock something oh oh yeah so
sabaha been said you should kill
civilians you only get one shot
literally one shot so you if you kill a
civilian that's it game over so that's
why yeah just go around killing everyone
because that would make it way too easy
mm-hmm yeah I've got different places so
I've got a courtyard and a high-rise
which he thinks should go in a courtyard
yeah okay
I was ski hard who should it be
Maria pizza is laughing that's good it's
nothing at me I think I can hear myself
echoing on your site already you're in
my head so I mean I'm in your head oh
yeah but you're in my head okay picture
person okay that's good I feel like
you're gonna get me I thought ik you
don't need to worry about me go you're
in the wheelchair
[Laughter]
[Music]
where is everyone
Oh God
banana bread I don't know where anyone
is I don't like this place it's too
difficult to see where everyone is god
dammit you [ __ ]
yeah
where are the statues probably I've got
do the statues don't you take it you're
like put me off the track here what you
mean you're like put me off the scent
talking about statues I don't know what
you're talking about
I feel like I'm gonna lose this I don't
think I'm gonna get everything well you
better check your time then not doing
anything
where are you
what's our time oh my god I'm totally
gonna lose I don't know anything I
haven't no oh no I know
quick you can get more time I can't
I'm too busy oh gosh okay
400 you were highlighted as well I
highlighted you I'll see you in the
Queen he was out of you the Queen yeah I
picked up the statues like three
different times or twice maybe it was
just twice okay one day I will kill you
one day was I not the bed oh did you
like that one yeah wider as the spikes
you can't just turn and see the whole
place you have to go round yeah Oh
everyone's talking about pizza I want
pizza hey get over nissan's
is the album done right no the albums
not done but it comes out soon this song
I've done the music video needs more
editing and I asked you do have a poster
to announce it soon oh yeah yeah it was
good yeah I did like actually think I
was gonna watch some of the stuff that I
found but I've got
I'll guess what it's my birthday in ten
days
oh my god that's come so greater than
that I know it really has it I feel like
I've blinked and April's like going I
know it's me the fifth but still I can't
wait I wonder what I'm doing but I can't
wait wait you can't actually choose your
spy can you it just like you yeah you
can drag you drag the green thing oh I
see yeah okay okay
and how do I change the oh here we go
here we go right so you just should we
do the highrise now cuz we haven't done
that yeah yeah why not okay
[ __ ] oh I'm gonna kill you oh thank you
I don't know how to say your name
Sabitha did I know I'm really sorry but
thank you for the birthday wishes yeah
if you want more epi what it's not
really an album that's more of an EP but
if you want more updates make sure to
follow my discord I think in the
description you'll be out in May so I'm
excited it's good jeiza that's next
month
oh my god I need to finish that music
video oh oh this is weird
well thanks guys for the birthday wishes
oh my god this is difficult there's two
rooms I don't like it mm-hmm
right these people don't exist
oh is that
you're the queen the queen looks so
shifty she dances and she just let the
real cream yeah
banana bread okay right it's not you
guys be sneaky Gazza sneaking hmm I
think you're this person I just had like
a boom as you did that it was like it
was like you did it don't go hiding from
me oh my god I know who you are I know
who you are
no come out Romina Reed Remini need me I
love banana breeds this is definitely oh
wait no it's not you oh is this person
check your watch a day oh yeah you walk
away
I definitely think you're the queen I'm
shaking the Queen sassy Beach she's
sassy beach don't lie to me I love it
the one game I'm like amazing at and
there's other people watching like this
never happens I'm usually rubbish I
thought you were quite a few different
people to be fair I wanna play destiny
now yeah okay come on I gotta get better
I can only go up from here this is the
bottom I'll call my way to the top
intermediate tell you okay don't even
look at the chart because they tell of
it I haven't been like I know I know but
they're telling you and I'm not okay
with this people I'm saying happy
birthday to me thank you Nikki thank you
young kid kink it and Yolo Renaissance
[Laughter]
Queen school that's it Queen stream yeah
Riley said give us a little hats like
that little green hats mmm Lulu who
should I be but no I'm gonna be this guy
Oh
[Music]
guys can you actually help me this time
please no cuz I haven't been reading
that chat that's discriminative it's not
I'm just young king kid said we should
play Ouija I'm not gonna play Ouija
boards no thanks nothing's Amit he says
we should call it team stream instead
where do we do the high rise again yeah
I forgot it was playing for a minute
to reduce hmm the Dinky's huh
nothing
boop-boop boop-boop
are you the tiny tiny man the tiny tiny
man oh yes
punch of a sudden I'm the tiny tiny man
with tiny tiny man in the end of bread
banana bread it really makes me want
your mum's banana bread to be fair oh
[Music]
come on judge
[Music]
[Music]
freaking me out
oh my god
it's time I got left a minute no Minnie
oh my god oh my god oh my gosh oh I was
so close to finishing everything this is
like basically why did you know I'm
gonna tell you my tactic your tactics
things you were reading what Nicky was
saying no I actually wasn't I promise
you I wasn't that was all me please give
it to me because I need it okay Oh me I
thought you saw me swap the statue cuz I
could see you were looking about you I'm
basically like Dee highlighted like Dee
is that weird like pretty much everyone
apart from you and like two other people
and then I was like okay I'm gonna go
when I wear my pretty sure it says
present yes right that's what I've done
I guess I just feel like thinking of
their actions and I was like okay Amy
wouldn't do that she wouldn't do that
she wouldn't do that shoot and then I
was like okay go and then I had the
banana bread and I was like okay it's
gonna be someone near a crowd of people
or no and that that was that that woman
so I was like well okay where should we
do it in the higher oh where the high
rise again no I'll do courtyard for you
okay you can try that one
yeah I think that one's harder yeah
although like there's a whole part of it
that you can never see when you're the
sniper cuz I've see you've got to go
around it yeah hmm we'll see I might not
get you this time we shall see
oh she won my team
hmm
okay I think I know who you are hmm any
in the red yes I totally know who you
are
no no what do you mean oh what a
material I am nobody
I am nobody
and in the red this is difficult
be naming then your bread
this is really difficult I'll come on
Nikki say something to me he's like I'm
not saying anything mm-hmm
you're not these people
Oh who's Bob [ __ ] no I had one more to
go oh oh I thought you were the old dude
I can't my going up to the personals for
sisters juice and it wouldn't let me
seduce her sometimes you have to be
close to them I bought clothes like
super-close
yeah but if you should seduce them
earlier you'd like give it time you
seduced at all it was like telling me to
do other actions instead I don't know it
was weird
we only saw three options
wait how by the Q and E buttons all the
scroll okay okay I know the next time
[Laughter]
any of you stick to your guns or you'll
end up with the short straw that was fun
Who am I gonna be oh I don't know who's
gonna be I'm gonna be I'm gonna be this
girl yeah you be that girl I do you do
you yeah okay
okay okay I'll just go back to being the
casual girl all right guys did we see
through Amy the targets
okay I'm ready
she ready Maria thinks you're definitely
a guy okay Maria you can think that
maybe I'm not maybe I am
who knows maybe she's booth Jenna's
fluid so I don't think you guys should
be good like trying to define my gender
oh yeah I gotta accept sorry yeah the
queen is the ambassador
you're not supposed to say banana break
[Music]
wait I'm I'm highlighting the wrong way
oh yeah pork I've messed up my system
when it's my sister doo-doo-doo-doo guys
what do you think do I got so mess up
because I was highlighting who I was
supposed to be d-lighting the chine Ikki
said white dresses like [ __ ] I was
doing all of the things to try and make
you not look at me so I think hopeful I
can see you like not really looking at
me so I thought I was a bit clear yes
Sarah no okay let's do this
oh I've knocked the balcony mmm oh okay
wait we've got a new one okay I'll do
that
yeah okay oh I only have three missions
so this must mean it's kind of hard oh
great tastic testes I think I'm like
mushroom it's hard for me though because
I only have to do three not four hey
Nicky said maybe he's still helping me
[ __ ] you I like your friends gasps this
is good
I am the one who puts effort in to edit
videos and stuff when they don't even
help me when I need it wait is it just
about me
where's the statues though oh wait bug
ambassador oh you don't have her oh my
god this is it's gonna be everyone great
brilliant great brilliant hmm a mom to
you oh okay
this is difficult I know right oh wait
did we run out of time i won what did
you do everything I'm confused
[Music]
we were out of time I'm so confused that
was weird
okay well I'm gonna check I don't like
the balcony about these two [ __ ] yeah
I'm gonna I'm just going to the ballroom
again boram's nice oh wait no but I'm
shooting hmm where do the high-rise oh
wait no I'm the spy I get confused
hmm I was like what if I did two of them
I just had one after I just had to
seduce the person but then it just
thought I did it Oh
I was like okay cool I walked up to the
person I'm supposed to be seducing and
then it says that I did it but I hadn't
even pressed the button so that's really
strange
yeah I don't know maybe the game was
just being nice I felt sorry for me
here maybe it was like you have no
chance I'm just gonna you win sir right
right right okay okay I'm ready
Oh back on highways okay yeah high-res
mojo oh the missions are any three or
four so you have four missions you only
have to do three I'm going to everything
apart I did win yes that was so quick
though I was like I haven't shot anyone
in a long time and he's shoot someone
no I realize maybe maybe you sometimes
is hiring people is hard that's why
they're waiting
the interbred be Nene Nene bread turn in
the bread
dude
oh my god I feel like I just let myself
lose wow why the newest okay how do I do
this oh my god
is that you
yeah when am I looking at you definitely
know you're a hunter side if you ya know
what you did it I don't know with you
you know like I love lies you oh I'm so
sneaky
yes I know I'm basically a spy but
someone said they think it's a woman in
the red dress was that me I think girls
wearing red nose yeah with you yeah I
literally was just walking around I kept
stopping outside of the little boxes
fell I could like over it over again I'm
the sniper oh I hate high-rises the
hardest I feel
hmm the other way oh okay oh it can't be
here
you're the queen oh yes darling oh my
god her in here
oh you're the short guy again I thought
he saw I thought I saw him bugging
someone but maybe he was just being very
short dude she's somewhat okay a part of
you there's a puppy in McQueen's Paris
yeah yeah there is whoa I want to be the
queen who don't want to be I'm gonna be
I probably have to go soon by the way
yeah oh yeah no we would you want to say
one more genies good like now no we can
do a couple more yeah okay cool oh I
forgot was a spy you is just be you
and in the red Benina [ __ ] bread
banana bread
No
this is really hard
just put the time up maybe see I think
you're the same woman maybe I am the red
dress
oh [ __ ] did you do it yeah I had no idea
I know like you I know I'm gonna get so
good at this I'm getting worse I'm like
oh yeah I'm blending into the background
it's good hmm okay wouldn't would you
like one or two more yeah it's up to you
you've got a daddy one each for yes you
have what I did I know what you're gonna
have oh it's vegetable soup yeah this
was nice
I'm like half the liver bread half a
little friend will you be spread for
soup and then the breads delicious
another true that's true yeah and then
that's it yeah I keep low lighting
people who don't need to low like oh I
always do that too wait where did you go
and in the red mm-hmm it's one of you
[ __ ]
this no this one this one this is really
difficult banana bread
[ __ ]
I think you are
thank you with this person yeah I
definitely think you're this person yes
I think it's because you just walked
like into someone and then you were like
banana bread and you were just like in
the middle of someone yeah I keep like
trying to do something and then someone
will move and then it will just
automatically do the fake banana bread
thing yeah I'm like no I I meant do
another thing but it already started so
I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah dad
it's okay well thanks for watching guys
do you wanna do understand anything Amy
thank you thanks for the birthday wishes
and everything and thanks for watching
the one game that I'm good at
I'm usually absolutely terrible terrible
okay you're good at yeah true yeah I'm
very good at Mario Kart we all have okay
ending account from all Queen streams
clean stream with payee team stream it
will be happening more often we probably
eat the X it's fun because we get to
hang out - yeah exactly
mhm yeah so anyway thank you very much
for watching let's say goodbye to people
we can see in the chat so okay bye
oh thanks Robin a bye Robin bye young
king kid and Maria pizza by Edward
Westmoreland Kwanzaa by Jackson Jack buy
half an hour Lisa bye wait did you say
young king kid yeah well bye again
bye Robyn LAN LAN art bye Rosa
ah this is the only sumo always watched
when I can catch it that's nice yeah bye
Oh who else is here Dustin echoes by tip
Arabic I think oh by onan Myers have you
said that yeah I don't know I think
we're saying by screw loose
but I like Edward Westmoreland confirm
oh by Alex Williams blinded by my Luke
ads by Toros bye everyone bye everyone
Owen good bye bye bye bye bye
okay three two one your evening bye